sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
begrüße sehr herzlich zur
pressekonferenz anlässlich der
präsentation des bundesheers am
nationalfeiertag zur pressekonferenz mit
verteidigungsministerien magister
klaudia tanner mit dem
militärkommandanten von wien brigitte
kurt wagner mit den schäfern orf 2
alexander hofer und mit oscar
preisträger aus caruso whisky und ich
darf die frau bundesministerin suchen
wie den ausführungen zu beginnen
sehr geehrte damen und herren heuer
jährt sich zum 25 mal die informations
und leistungsschau des österreichischen
bundesheeres und dieses mal wohl unter
ganz besonderen bedingungen
ich freue mich wirklich sehr dass wir
trotz der geltenden cobit restriktionen
mit dieser ganz besonderen form einer
übrigen form der veranstaltung nämlich
dem virtuellen heldenplatz
nationalfeiertag 2020 punkt jetzt der
live berichterstattung des orf dafür
auch ein ganz großes dankeschön
alexander hofer und privater tv-sender
sowie den kurzfilmen des großartigen und
oscar prämierten regisseur stefan
ruzowitzky heuer für ein ganz besonderes
live gefühl sorgen werden in österreich
wohnzimmern und eine ganz besonders
große reichweite erreichen werden davon
sind wir alle überzeugt sondern dieser
stelle auch ein ganz großes dankeschön
für ihre bereitschaft das
österreichische bundesheer präsentiert
sich dabei unter dem motto wir schützen
österreich mit vier themenbereichen sind
dabei im besonderen fokus und werden zum
einen in den kurzfilmen von stefan
ruzowitzky eis auch bei virtuellen
themeninseln näher dargestellt zum einen
ist es die militärische
landesverteidigung als unsere
kernaufgabe als die kernaufgabe des
bundesheeres zum 2
der katastrophenschutz zum trinken dann
der aktuelle kogit 19 einsatz
sie wissen ja dass darum auch die
erstmalig in der geschichte der republik
erstmalige aufbietung auch der medizin
wendig geworden ist sowie zum vierten
das jubiläum nämlich 60 jahre
auslandseinsatz
es wird am montag dann die grenzen der
legung des herrn bundespräsidenten und
der bundesregierung stattfinden und
danach werden hier am heldenplatz
feierlich 300 rekruten eingeloggter auch
davon von diesen drei frauen drei
rekrutinnen er es wird einen überflug
gegeben von einer formation saab 105 und
einer formation eurofighter die direkt
hier über den heldenplatz
stattfinden wird das wird bei etwa gegen
11 uhr sein
es werden vier fallschirmspringer
unseres jagdkommandos 1500 metern von
einem black hawk hubschrauber mit der
geplanten landung dann am 26
oktober gegen 12 uhr mit den fahnen
europas mit den fahnen von österreich
mit der fahne von wien sowie auch bei
jagd romano verbands fahne abspringen
dies alles mit einer live kamera ich
oder wir sind überzeugt davon dass wir
mit diesem programm in dieser neuen
hybriden form der veranstaltung den
virtuellen heldenplatz nationalfeiertag
2020 punkt jetzt der live
berichterstattung des orf vielen dank
noch einmal und privater tv-sender sowie
den kurzfilmen hier noch einmal ein
dankeschön an stefan ruzowitzky ein ganz
besonderes live gefühl in besonderen
zeiten in die wohnzimmer der
österreicherinnen und österreicher
bringen werden
dankeschön
der sehr geehrte frau bundesministerin
meine sehr geehrten damen und jahren als
militärkommandant von wien darf ich wie
immer einige details noch zum
programmablauf am nationalfeiertag
selbst bringen die bereits angesprochene
ganze verlegung des herrn
bundespräsidenten im bauraum des äußeren
burgtor es erfolgt um 9 uhr 30
daran anschließend erfolgt um 10 uhr die
grenze verlegung der bundesregierung
unmittelbar vor beginn der angelobung
und so wissen die angelobung beginnt um
11 uhr also unmittelbar davor gibt es
den überflug der beiden formationen von
saab 105 und eurofightern angeles
begeben 11 uhr mehr als 300 regionen und
rekruten werden angelockt
das stärkste kontingent kommt von der
garde und auf der anderen seite kommt
der stärkste kontingent tag was die
bundes und der betriebsrat will den
abschluss der angelobung wird quasi
durch den fallschirmabsprung erfolgen
der bundesministerin hat das bereits
angesprochene es wird dabei auch eine
live-übertragung aus einem durch einen
kameramann aus dem flug heraus von dem
fall springen geben
die toffees sicherheitsbestimmungen
werden hier natürlich für die
veranstaltung insgesamt eingehalten
wir sind hier in sehr engem kontakt mit
der stadt drin und der zuständigen
behörde ema 15
die sanitäts versorgung am platz zu
übernehmen hier auf seiner seite des
untersees auf der anderen seite auch in
bewährter weise die johanniter
normalerweise wissen sie gibt es eine
informations und leistungsschau hier am
ort das kern aus bekannten gründen heute
in der traditionellen weise nicht
erfolgen
und statt diese analogen schaut gibt es
eben die digitale und die möglichkeit
sich unter dem nationalfeiertag 2020
punkte jetzt zu informieren
neben der direktübertragung des orf oder
anderer interessiert was ändern werde
ich alle ersuchen nicht auf den
heldenplatz zu kommen sondern sich die
live-übertragungen
anzuschauen beziehungsweise online
einzusteigen und sich hier einblick zu
machen von den aufgaben des bundesheers
von bestimmten waffensystemen von touré
wohl über den hubschrauber s70 über
media container bis zu sandruper und
nicht zu vergessen kurz würden wir die
die aufgaben des bundesheeres darstellen
und der einzelnen porträts von soldaten
noch abschließend ein wort zu den kosten
die gesamtkosten werden etwa 400.000
euro betragen
das sieht aber auch viele teile
inkludiert die ja nicht nur einmal für
die heutige veranstaltung zur
nationalfeier genutzt werden können
sondern kurz geben wir überhaupt haben
das bundesheer es die porträts die
können auch in weiterer folge noch lange
genutzt werden
vielen dank herr offer bitte der geehrte
frau bundesministerin sehr geehrter herr
brega der biber stefan ruzowitzky darf
an dieser stelle die besten grüße von
orf generaldirektor dr farbe zu
überbringen der leiter aus terminlichen
gründen verhindert ist an diesem
heutigen pressegespräch persönlich
teilzunehmen und so darf ich in seiner
vertretung einen kleinen überblick über
das geben was das orf publikum an diesem
besonderen sechsundzwanzigster oktober
am vormittag zu erwarten hat für uns
alle ist es eine premiere für uns alle
ist es eine besondere form der
zusammenarbeit für die ich mich an
dieser stelle lieber vom bundesminister
auch ganz ganz ausdrücklich und von
herzen im namen des orf bedanken will
darauf übernimmt sozusagen an diesem tag
die funktion des tags der offenen tür
und in amman gelungen der möglichkeit
hier direkt und persönlich am
heldenplatz vorbeizukommen und sich die
militärischen präsentation anzuschauen
wir freuen uns sehr auf diese aufgabe
wir werden diesen tag um 9 uhr 5 in orf
2 beginnen und etwa bis 12 15 live
senden wir werden nicht nur den besuch
hier am heldenplatz virtuell und über
die live übertragung
möglich ermöglichen wir werden auch
ermöglichen einen live blick in den
sonderministerrat zu ermöglichen der an
diesem tag traditionell takt wir werden
bei den kerns niederlegung an dabei sein
wir werden jede menge zuspielungen aus
dem archiv aber auch aus der hand und
der kameraführung des oscar preisträgers
auf sendung bringen können
wir haben zwei schauplätze dafür
etabliert einerseits im orf-zentrum am
küniglberg kollegin margit lafer mit
experten durch die gesamte live
übertragung führen wird an ihrer seite
innenpolitik chef hans bürger und
generalmajor bruno hofbauer die und das
finde ich persönlich spannend ein
bisschen einblick ins protokoll geben
können also dazu sehr die zuseherinnen
erfährt an diesem tag ein bisschen mehr
hintergründe warum findet etwas in
dieser form statt wer sind die
handelnden personen welchen ausdruck
haben behandlungen die hier am
nationalfeiertag gesetzt werden wir
haben bei der zusammensetzung der
moderatorin oder des moderatorenteams
auch darauf geachtet dass wir sehr viele
frauen und da man einsetzen es ist nicht
nur margit lauf vor im orf zentrum
sondern hier im bundeskanzleramt aus der
parlamentsredaktion die kollegin rebecca
seitzer die sich live melden wird und
aus der chronik redaktion saskia venen
was wie das thema unterstützt wir haben
keinen oscar preisträger in den reihen
unserer fernsehregisseure aber wir haben
jemanden der die wirklich großen events
und veranstaltungen immer hervorragend
in szene zu setzen gewusst hat professor
kurz pongratz zuletzt über die grenzen
österreichs hinaus mit der übertragung
des eurovision song contest aus dem jahr
2015 bekannt geworden er wird hier
gemeinsam mit dem österreichischen
bundesheer die regie der übertragung
führen
ich darf mich an dieser stelle noch
einmal für die zusammenarbeit auch im
vorfeld zum zustandekommen dieser
übertragung gedanken bei ihnen bei euch
ich kann nur das publikum ein
ab 9 uhr 54 orf 2 am nationalfeiertag
dabei zu sein
ich glaube es wird ein spannender und
sehr informativer vormittag ich glaube
auch dass damit die möglichkeit gegeben
wird über die stadtgrenze hinaus den
österreichischen fernsehpublikum auch in
den bundesländern einmal die möglichkeit
zu geben an diesem tag an diesem
festlichen tag dabei zu sein an einem
symbolträchtigen tag in einem
außergewöhnlichen jahr herzlichen
dankeschön so bietet der minister sehr
geehrte damen und herren ich bin
eigentlich nur silva rammt hier um ein
paar wenige worte aber wenn er sich
präsentiert über über eine frau einen
migranten und einen behinderten mann ist
dieses heer im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert angekommen
dann ist das auch mein her und deswegen
war ich auch stolz eingeladen zu sein
diese präsentation zu gestalten
ich habe die diskussion ein bisschen
mitbekommen jahr in diesen filmen kommen
auch schwere waffen vor
wobei bei meiner meinung nach und dass
das glaube ich sieht man dann auch in
den filmen die schwerste und effektivste
waffe ist dass das heer gelernt hat wie
auf unsere gesellschaft dass jeder
mensch was beitragen kann
in her aber eben auch in der
gesellschaft in der republik
ich glaub ich wie alle hier würden uns
wünschen dass es keine kriege gäbe dass
man keine herre bräuchte so ist es aber
nicht deswegen sehe ich es auch als
meine aufgabe wie jeder bürger dass man
sich bemüht dass dieses her so gut wie
möglich da steht dieses heer eines eines
demokratischen landes und da habe ich
das gefühl dass das durchaus einem
richtigen weg ist und das habe ich eben
versucht dann auch ein bisschen film ich
und auch propagandistisch diese diese
gute richtung
sie verarbeiten und zu zeigen
danke herzlichen dank ich darf sie nun
um ihre fragen suchen und darf sie
ersuchen zu warten bis das mikrofon bei
ihnen ist an der milter kommandanten
eine nachfrage werden hier jetzt
irgendwelche geräte besser ausgestellt
und wie viele flugzeuge machen diese
formation als solche am heldenplatz gibt
es keine präsentationsform fahrzeugen es
werden zwar einzelne fahrzeuge da sein
aber kein fahrzeug wird präsentiert und
keine es wird für die öffentlichkeit
daher zugänglich sein
zum ersten zum zweiten die formation ist
gedacht mit 1435 weitere frage
eine frage an den herren ruzowitzky es
wurde erwähnt ganz tolle setzt ihr her
weil frauen vorkommen migranten und
behinderte kennen sie das ein bisserl
genauer ausführen
nicht nur natürlich aber eben auch und
ich glaube so dieses es gibt so ein
oldschool vorstellungen vom perfekten
soldaten der groß blond blauäugig stark
und ein bisschen doof ist das ist wie
gesagt vergangenheit und ich glaube
wirklich dass entsprechend einem einen
diversen auch gesellschaft ideal das
eben auch dass er gelernt hat dass jeder
was beitragen kann
egal woher kommt das jeder spezielle
fähigkeiten hat die zu nutzen sind wenn
man die richtige einstellung hat wenn
man die richtigen fähigkeiten hat dass
dieses dieses bild was ein guter soldat
ist was ein guter soldat zeigen kann
dass sich das einfach verbreitet hat und
dass das finde ich eine sehr positive
entwicklung
ja danke eine zusatzfrage behinderung
ist ist das eine geistige oder eine
körperliche behinderung
es ist seit ein paar jahren sind auch
behinderten sportler beim heer dabei
also das ist da walter ablinger die wir
da
porträtiert haben der eben jetzt seinen
sport mit unterstützung des heeres
ausüben kann und irgendwie bin ich dann
wenn man darüber nachdenkt kommt man
drauf
er macht jetzt auch nicht weniger oder
an marcel hirscher oder ich weiß nicht
wer noch bei euch ist macht nicht mehr
es geht immer darum dass da jemand
gewinnt sich anstrengt über eigene
grenzen hinaus geht damit ein vorbild
eine inspiration ist und das kann ein
behinderten sportler genauso wie ein
weltbekannter spitzensportler gut wenn
es keine weiteren fragen gibt dann
bedanke ich mich willkommen und beende
hiermit die pressekonferenz dankeschön